The second reason why people are lazy is because you're afraid.
You're afraid.
You're afraid of actually doing the thing that you want to do.
You know what your Michael Jordan level talent is.
You know where your ET level talent is, but you're afraid to chase it down.
You're afraid to take the stage.
You're afraid to make that call.
You're afraid to say, here's what I do.
You're afraid to bet on yourself.
You're afraid.
So laziness or procrastination comes from not having a dream
or having one and being afraid of it.
Either way, the answer is action.
If you don't know what your dream is, your answer is to go and take immediate action
to try out as many things as possible.
To say yes, to try anything once to find your dream.
Or if your problem is you know your dream, but you're afraid of it, then the answer is still action.
You have to get up and do it because otherwise you will live the rest of your life in regret
knowing that you could have done more.
Knowing that you lived your life doing things that you hated.